Sun has Lyme disease. I believe it's phase 3 automobile. Okay, so this person has read my information. So that's good.
What should he do moving forward?
So I understand.
Lyme disease historically has been acute Lyme disease chronic Lyme disease.
And the separated factor of that is the acute Lyme disease is relatively curable through use of antibiotics.
So an antibiotic will kill the Borrelia, Virgidorophy, but it's in the blood and in the tissues.
But once the bacteria goes intracellular inside of a cell, antibiotics will kill it.
And it can reproduce inside the cell and it can wait for the opportunity never bacteria, viruses, pathogens or opportunistic organisms.
It can wait for the opportunity where it's safe to go back outside the cell, reproduce even more, make a person sicker.
And then when your immune system kicks up, it goes back inside the cell, protects itself.
There's other avenues that the bacteria has to protect itself, makes itself part of the Borrelia microbiota, protects itself with a waste layer around it.
There's other protective measurements that Virgidorophy has.
But if it's moved into that chronic phase, and it's that person has had this chronic Lyme disease for a long enough, as your immune system continues to try to kill it, it keeps going inside the cell.
There can be a time where your immune system now makes antibodies against your own tissue in the attempt to kill, to sacrifice the tissue to kill the disease.
So now you have antibodies to self-tissue, so now you moved into what I termed phase three Lyme.
Phase three Lyme, by definition, is that you made antibodies against your own tissue, so now you're really an autoimmune disease.
Now, once you're in phase three Lyme, you have antibodies to self-tissue, that Borrelia lets pretend that the Borrelia came outside the cell, your immune system killed it, and now it isn't even present anymore.
You run an IgM test for Borrelia, and it's a negative, and you don't have any current IgM antibodies, but you don't have any current infection.
You do a CD4-CDA test, you have no current infection.
Your symptoms, though, oh, I'm so sick, how could I not have a current infection? I feel so ill, I don't feel well, and this has been this way for eight years since I got Lyme disease.
I'm happy to say I don't have a current infection. Well, you could be that ill, or worse, with an autoimmune disease, your symptoms are really from the autoimmune disease, from the destruction of self-tissue.
And it can be any brand of autoimmune disease, any named autoimmune disease, because an autoimmune disease is named after, it's either a systemic autoimmune disease, like Lupus, or it's a tissue-specific autoimmune disease, like Hashimoto's,
you know, tissue-specific to the cerebellum, or tissue-specific to violent sheet cells.
So, the name of the autoimmune disease has to do with the antibodies that are being produced, self-activated, as they're reproduced.
So, that is what's called phase three autoimmune. How do you question this? How do you treat this moving forward? Well, you have to make sure you're not taking the immune stimulants.
But the best way is to go to our cuttersclinic.com site, excuse me,
and in $50 purchase, our autoimmune course. So, purchasing our autoimmune course, you know, walk through the steps of really how to treat any autoimmune disease, whether it's
was originated from this Lyme infection, or originated from mold, or originated from toxins in our environment, or from glyphosate, or pesticides, or other sorts, or whatever originated from, it doesn't make any difference.
Now that you have self-empty bodies, you have to treat this condition completely different.
So, that course will help you understand how to treat it moving.
There's lots of different steps to take. So, go through that course, and if you have questions, if you need support, need help, you can make an appointment through a case review.